this is a comprehensive paper review of
the paper transformer memory as a
differentiable search index this paper
is pretty crazy it takes an entire data
set and puts it into the weights of a
transformer essentially it trains a
search engine not to search through
documents but just to give you the index
of the document that matches your query
just like that boom so this video is a
comprehensive review of the paper i'll
explain to you what's in the paper what
it's about and by the end of the video
you should have a good idea of the paper
itself the next video which i'm going to
release tomorrow will be an interview
with the authors we'll dive right into
the content and any criticisms and
questions that i raised during the
review as always let me know what you
think in the comments so now let's get
into the video see you around
does your company have a lot of people
labeling data why would you leave such
an important task to closed source
systems or self-implemented things
training data is your most valuable
asset and human labels are really
expensive today's sponsor is diffgram
which is an open source platform
centered around training data they
handle everything to do with training
data especially collecting labeling
serving and more and it is open source
so you can self-host all you want but
there's one cool thing if you let them
host it for you and that is unlimited
pricing no per label annotation no
expensive servers to run you pay once
you get as much as you want so thanks
again to diffgram for sponsoring today's
video check them out using the link in
the description to let them know that i
sent you all right let's get into the
video
hello there today we're looking at
transformer memory as a differentiable
search index by researchers of google
research this paper on high level takes
a search problem where you have to index
documents and retrieve them and it puts
all of the corpus essentially into the
weights of a transformer so it takes the
corpus and trains the transformer and
then at the end they can just give a
query to the transformer and the
transformer will output the id of the
document that matches and it turns out
for some data sets that they have for
some settings and with some clever
training and representation of the
documents that can actually work which
is really crazy
this kind of speaks to multiple things
such as obviously our ability to overfit
on stuff but there is some
generalization here as we'll see on the
other hand also the
kind of inner workings of these
transformers and lastly what's pretty
cool is that this is completely as it
says differentiable it's a
differentiable search index which means
that this can be part of larger neural
network architectures because it is
fully differentiable and it can be
trained essentially end to end at once
and that means we can potentially employ
reinforcement learning agents with kind
of retrieval abilities and much more
things so
we'll dive into the paper we'll see what
it's about the idea as i said is pretty
pretty simple if you like content like
this then as always leave a like and
tell me what you think in the comments
that's always super helpful so
as i said they
take they take a search problem and the
search problem is essentially i have a
corpus like i have a big database of of
documents right here is a document
here's a document
and i want to build an index and an
index is
some kind of data structure some some
kind of thing
and at the index i can throw a query
and the index will return to me an id a
document id
that specifies which document matches my
query usually this is done via inverted
indices so i want to tokenize my
documents split them into little tokens
which are usually words or sub words and
i want to stem them and lemmatize them
and whatnot then i build a revert
reverse index so for every word like in
the word in i i remember which documents
it appears in like document 3 document 5
document 11 and so on and then once the
query rolls in i simply tokenize it as
well i go look into my inverted index
and i look up all the documents and then
there's also a ranking step which means
i have to now determine which of these
documents is the most relevant and that
is usually done via techniques like
tf idf features there is a famous
technique called bm25
which
is also a baseline in this paper
so this is the classic uh search kind of
way way of doing search if you
use any search engine at all this is
being done in the background
for the most part newer search engines
are catching on there's neural search
and so on but vm 25 is still one of the
most performant
things that text search as available and
also other types of search
however there is a new push in sort of
neural search and in neural search
you're trying to take your data set and
for each document you try to map it to
some sort of a vector in vector space
and then once the query comes in you
also map the query to a vector and for
example you compare inner products
whichever inner product is largest
that's the document that's relevant this
is just one way this is what we usually
call a by encoder method where the
documents in the queries are mapped both
mapped individually so there will be an
encoder
here and there would be an encoder here
they all would output one vector and
then the vectors are compared this could
be the same encoder or different
encoders for documents in query
this is just one method there's various
methods such as cross encoders
re-rankers dense retrievers you name it
um
however this method here is even more is
different so
what we want to do is we want to take
the corpus as such and uh map that
somehow into a neural network and we're
going to talk about this somehow but
we're going to train a neural network
essentially how do we represent this
let's represent it with its layers
such that um
when later i feed a query to the neural
network
as i already said the id of the document
is the output of the neural network so
it doesn't output a vector that i then
go and compare
it doesn't i don't have to go and feed
in query document pairs and then i get
out a score of how well they fit
together which what i would do in a
cross encoder no the transformer in this
case the neural network directly gives
me the id of the document which
without
seeing the data at inference time so
during training
all of the data is essentially has to be
mapped somehow into the weights of the
neural networks right so somewhere in
these weights that information is stored
of what the documents are so the entire
corpus is in those weights and
once i enter a query
the correct document id can only be
output obviously if the
transformer has somehow learned what is
in those documents so that's the setup
this pretty simple setup once you
kind of see what's going on
it's it's like a meme right uh instead
of we've been trying to neuralize search
and we've still done this two-step
process where we train these encoders
but then the actual search is still done
using for example a nearest neighbor
algorithm like here
but you know this is just the idea of
well why don't i just ask the neural
network to output the result right the
resulting dock id why don't i just do
that
and it turns out that can work
surprisingly well
so
um
you can do
large a couple of things here but
that's essentially it
they say right here in the introduction
they use a sequence to sequence learning
system
to directly map a query to a relevant
document id
the they have different corpuses where
they train it on on the smallest corpus
this method improves the hits at one
which means that whether the top it hit
is the correct one
more than 20 points from 12.4
for a dual encoder so the baseline here
is a dual encoder what i shown
whenever the
there are two encoders and they each
output an embedding
to 33.9 that's a giant gain right that's
like a 2.5 x improvement
however on a corpus that's 30 times
larger performance is improved by nearly
7 points which is less
it's also respectable that performance
is improved at all however i want you to
notice and that's already kind of the
first indication a little bit of
obviously what's going on here
on smaller data sets this method does
super duper well on larger data sets the
method doesn't do that much better than
a sort of cross encoder type setup sorry
a buy encoder type setup or a dual
encoder type setup which is
understandable right because the smaller
the data the easier it is to absorb it
all into your weights
if the data gets larger that obviously
gets harder and harder there's more data
to go around which means there's more
error room for error for confusion and
so on and a
classic uh search engine or a dual
encoder is going to have a easier time
in that case but still it's a cool cool
paper
um it's just that it it kind of gets
worse with the dataset scale
it does get better with the model scaled
though
the really exciting thing is something
that i've already mentioned and they
mentioned this here all aspects sorry
about that
they say all aspects
of retrieval are mapped into
well-understood machine learning tasks
so for example indexing which is
building the reverted index or even if
you have the dual encoder you need to
build the nearest neighbor index which
is a hard task in high dimensions is now
a special case of model training so it's
just training and
incrementally updating an index becomes
just a special case of model updating so
all the tasks are just tasks that we
already understand from neural network
training
so here is a
a comparison of the dual encoder method
uh which is the let's say old classic
neural search method not the bm 25
retrieval but the neural surge method
and this dsi differentiable search index
so in the dual encoder method what we do
is we train this encoder and in this
case they train one encoder for both the
queries
as well as the documents and what we try
to do is
we are going to try to use some form of
contrastive loss if we actually have
query document pairs what we can do is
we can try to get the documents
the query and the document that go with
each other to be close together
while making the documents that are
unrelated to each other be far apart so
this is some sort of contrastive loss
obviously at inference time
what we're going to do is we have a
query we put it through the encoder we
get its embedding and we do a maximum
inner product search through our entire
vector space of our of our
indexed data set and we get a ranked
list so it's kind of this two-step
approach with
building these indices in between and
with a training objective that is not
directly what we want it is a proxy
objective because of the algorithm later
needs it the inner product search
but
it is not actually what we want so let's
just train what we want
in the dsi and the differentiable search
index i simply feed um
my query along with i simply feed my
query essentially
to
um in some form to the system and the
system
outputs directly which document is
relevant for the query
so
the way they train it and this is one
way they train it um
is where they feed in queries and
documents into the
into the system
so this is an encoder decoder setup in
fact they use i believe a t5
setup if i'm not mistaken so it's a
sequence to sequence task
they feed in
the
queries and the documents and they
always output the document id so for if
they feed a document they just output
the id of the document they fed in and
if they feed a query they output the id
of the document that the query would hit
so this is if you have supervised data
you can train the system already for
given queries to output the correct
document however the method also works
in what they call zero shot which is if
you do not have any queries you simply
input documents into the
system and then you train it to output
the id of those documents and you hope
that because the models were pre-trained
on language modeling and on various
other tasks
you hope
that through that if you then enter a
query that kind of describes the same
thing as the documents that the system
would still output the best document id
i mean after all it's constrained to
output document ids in most cases and
therefore it needs to give you something
so it might as well give you the thing
that is related the most
so that's the reasoning behind it
i've talked a lot about the different
parts now of the system the write-up is
actually pretty good i can recommend
reading this paper
from top to bottom because it goes in a
very structured form into what they
investigate they investigate a lot of
engineering choices which i really
appreciate in the system because there
are a lot of ways to do this
and
not
one or the other is not necessarily
correct so they say we explore a number
of variations of the dsi architecture
they explore how do we represent
documents as such uh the naive approach
they say is just to index the full
document so just input the text
as such like you can see right here just
input the text into the encoder output
the document id that's it
but maybe that's not the best thing to
do maybe
you can throw away stop words maybe you
can
do bag of words representation maybe
something is better than just inputting
the first l tokens of the document
turns out it's not but you know it's a
good good thing to investigate
then how do we represent document ids
the data sets they usually just have
like some unique identifier per document
in this case it's like doc one three
seven and here it's doc four five six if
we do this as a sequence to sequence
tasks maybe we can do something smarter
maybe we can
uh give
the document ids some sort of
hierarchical notion they investigate
that too
and lastly they investigate how
should we index stuff
so
uh how how should exactly should the
indexing step this
training
go
they also do a lot of ablations on sort
of the effect of sizes the effect of
model size and corpus size and we're
going to look into that as well
so
the
method is called as i said
differentiable search index the goal is
to fully parameterize traditionally
multi-stage retrieval then rank
pipelines within a single neural model
and that encompasses two operations
first is indexing and then the second
one is retrieval
in the dsi we've already discussed this
indexing is a sequence to sequence
approach that takes a document that
takes document tokens as input and
generates identifiers as output that is
indexing its training on the document
collection to output their identifiers
and optionally optionally
fine-tuning with labeled query
sets labeled query doc id pairs
the retrieval is then achieved by simply
auto regressive generation i input
something and i see what document id
comes out in the sequence to sequence
model
so it couldn't get easier than that
let's look a different a little bit into
the engineering choices they consider
first the indexing method
the first indexing method is what they
call inputs to target and that is
probably what i've described so far
which is
the sequence to sequence task of
document tokens maps to document id so
they input the tokens of the document
and they output the document id
that is
the simplest method the straightforward
method from what we've heard so far and
as far as i've read in the paper as i
understand it this is also what works
the best
however
they
proclaim that
in this way the only ever output is the
document id there is no sort of language
learning or anything like this you fully
rely on the pre-training for a language
understanding that is what they claim
here is a potential weakness and other
methods are you know targeted at
um are targeted at
in sort of leveraging or
making that weakness go away they have
this targets to inputs method which they
say
we could also at training time at in
what they call indexing time input a
document id and then have the model
decode the tokens of the document now
this might seem a bit weird because it
doesn't train the model
to produce document ids from tokens but
the idea is that you could for example
then fine tune on query
document id pairs
and that by by training with the with
this objective
you teach the model something
about the document ids and which tokens
which document tokens are in the in the
ids because the model has to learn to
produce the document tokens and
therefore it might make some
associations or something i'm not
exactly sure what the
uh
thing is behind like what the reasoning
is behind this
but you know
you know
it's good to try it doesn't work turns
out there's also bi-directional which
both are done
so
during training there is like a
multi-task setup where sometimes you do
the dock id to tokens and sometimes you
do the tokens to dock id also in their
experiment the bi-directional method
doesn't improve much over just the plane
method and the last one is span
corruption where you essentially input i
think the the tokens
tokens and you append the doc id
and then you consider this entire thing
as like
one piece of text that you want to
predict and you have this span
corruption objective which means that
you can mark out any random spans in
here between which also means that
sometimes you mask out the document id
or maybe part of the document id and
that kind of forces the model to learn
it's a bit like bert's masked language
modeling if i understand this correctly
however also this doesn't seem to work
super well for them
even though it has actually worked well
in other tasks so in other papers that
have done
[Music]
things in in this sort of
sequence to sequence space
okay so now we have the indexing method
of the table
the document representation strategies
are next the first one is direct
indexing they say we take the first l
tokens
again this seems to work the best uh
just take the first l tokens of the
document interestingly during the
experiments
l
bigger isn't necessarily better for l
which is also
might speak to a little bit of the
quality and nature of the data set
itself
but also tells us again something about
uh maybe this works in particular
because we're dealing with sizes and
data set sizes and lengths of documents
that are actually possible to absorb
into weights and it is interesting to
see how as the data goes up this becomes
harder and harder i would question does
it become like linearly harder to put
this into a set of weights does it
become exponentially harder if there's
more data
not sure it would be interesting to find
out
the
other methods are for example set
indexing that which deduplicates
repeated terms and removes stop words
doesn't seem to help much and
you know naturally one might think that
you know if i remove stop words in my
document representation that gives me a
cleaner signal on the other hand these
models are pre-trained on actual
language not on cleaned up language
without stop words they're pre-trained
on actual language and therefore they i
think they have a strong bias towards
you know kind of correct grammar and so
on um and might work with that data a
lot better i think that might be largely
behind why the direct indexing method
works better over the set indexing
and then there's the in what they call
inverted index which is a bit in the
spirit of how search engines classically
do this they say we randomly sub sample
a single contiguous chunk of k tokens
from the document so they're not only
limited to the first l tokens but they
always kind of take a random sub string
of the document
that is of that length now technically
this should work better than the direct
indexing um
i
like
the
the inverted index in their experiment
performs worse than the direct indexing
and i just don't believe it like i like
it doesn't it does not make sense right
something's going on either the data set
is such that for some reason i can find
a lot of the answers that i'm looking
for in the first in the beginning
of the documents that are indexed but
this is purely a property of the data
set or it is really like the
introduction of a tiny bit of noise into
this namely that for the same document
id i see different sub strings i see
different tokens
um
that that already kicks the method out
of its out of its comfort zone that
seems to be
i like the in first instance it's kind
of a bummer that this is the data set
but we'll have to take it in the second
instance it's a bit more worrisome if
that were the case like if if that fact
would be
already detrimental where it actually
should be beneficial
or yeah maybe i'm misunderstanding
something but it seems to me that uh the
this last method should be superior to
the first one
so the last thing they or the next thing
they investigate is how do we represent
by the way i'm already i'm already
telling you about the experimental
results they're they'll be coming up in
the next section but i think it's
it's uh easier to mention them already
here than to keep everything in your
head and then go to the experimental
results but we will go into it in just a
bit
um they investigate how should we
represent the doc ids again the simplest
thing you can do is to have these
unstructured atomic identifiers which
essentially means that every document
gets a unique identifier and then in the
sequence to sequence model right i have
my sequence here
um this is in in goes into my encoder
and then it goes into a decoder
and the decoder produces a sequence now
every one of those tokens is
in a list in a vocabulary the vocabulary
has a certain amount of entries if i
tokenize correctly i have no out of
vocabulary words
and this has a some kind of a fixed size
like a vocabulary size
and the decoder it can have the same
vocabulary or a different vocabulary in
this case i think it's the same
but what they do in this first method is
they simply extend the vocabulary for
the decoder
and the extra tokens here every single
token is represents one document
id this obviously only works if you know
all the documents ahead of time that
you're going to index but in their case
they do so
they randomly initialize those
embeddings and during indexing they
train the embeddings for those
and that essentially means it's a
multi-class classification problem at
the end of the day
every
sequence prediction task is but we're
not going to predict multiple tokens
we're going to predict exactly one token
and that token comes exactly from this
vocabulary and that means this this is
not a sequence to sequence task this is
just a multi-class classification task
now this has advantages being
multi-class classification it means
there's one prediction there's no
auto-regressivity or anything like this
um it's essentially a classic
um
encoder only problem
though this is the easy part the hard
part is of course you you don't you
don't leverage anything you introduce a
lot of new classes a lot of new
embeddings
and
they claim in the experiments that these
things are quite brutal even though in
the zero shot case apparently they work
out super well
but we'll have some comments on that too
the next thing is naively structured
string identifiers they so they say
again like here every document will have
an arbitrary unique identifier which is
just kind of a
an integer
however they just say well we'll just
put the integer as a tokenizable string
so if the integers if the integer is
like 1 1 2 5
then the model needs to predict the
tokens like the strings one one two and
five or maybe it's tokenized differently
but
it will actually have to produce this
thing as a string not as a
output into an output classification
bucket but it will have to output the
string
so this is now truly a sequence to
sequence task right
and the last thing they consider
is these semantically structured
identifiers and they it's where they
think well can't we do something better
for the document ids like can't we imbue
them with some meaning and they come up
with the following procedure so they
have two they have two uh principles
they want to follow they say the doc id
should capture some information about
the semantics of its associated document
and second the doc id should be
structured in a way that search space is
effectively reduced after each decoding
step
this results in identifiers where
semantically similar documents share
identifier prefixes so essentially they
want
uh the documents to have multiple like
the i
the ids could be two five five which
essentially means it's like a path right
it's like a folder path so this is
super group 2 and then group 5 inside of
super group 2 and then document 5 inside
of that and the assumption is that all
the documents that are in the same like
group two slash five they share some
stuff
such that the decoder if it's not sure
which exact document it is but it can
already say well in super group two i
find all the things that talk about i
don't know household items and then in
two slash five there are all the things
that talk about
electric appliances in the household and
then inside of that there might be some
documents but
the model could consider step by step
the model would first consider
outputting sort of the super group and
then condition on that in order to
output the group and then condition on
that in order to output the next level
so that's what they do they do a
hierarchical clustering approach which
means that they take another model so
they take
some sort of a um
i think it's a bird model
a bird
i think i'm not sure where they mention
it
but they take a bird model they
put all of the documents through the
bert model they train an embed i don't
know if they actively train it or if
they take a pre-trained one in any case
they have some way of embedding
documents so they embed those documents
then they use k-means clustering to
divide them into clusters if the
clusters are still too large they
recursively subdivide
them into
clusters and here you see exactly so
this this here this here is document two
three three because it's in super group
two it's in subgroup three so that's two
three and then it's the third document
inside of that so that's two three three
and presumably the two and the three pre
the prefixes um
they're kind of like the path into the
hierarchy and make it easier for the
model to decode now this seems like a
seems like a cool
idea
honestly because it kind of makes sense
there are however two conflicting things
one is the fact that there is semantic
meaning in you know in 255 or 233 in
that case right there is semantic
meaning in these things and not just a
random identifier the other one is that
um it is in order so the top hierarchy
is first then the second then the third
which might interplay with the
autoregressive way that we train these
things
so in order to separate the two things
one would need to make an experiment
where you just flip it around right you
decode while you decode you do you
decode from the back you decode like
three three two right and then you you
essentially still retain the
um the semantic information of the
identifier but you drop away the
autoregressivity so the model
essentially would uh could not condition
on the super group while decoding the
lower layers so you could tease that
apart a little bit
they didn't do that but in any case this
would i guess be an idea of doing
further ablation and understanding into
how this model works it is interesting
um
they
yeah that's that's it essentially okay
then how do they train they say we try
two strategies
one is to first
to train the indexing step so first feed
the documents and output their ids
followed by a fine tuning stage
where you feed queries and map them to
their ids
or the second strategy is to train them
together in a multi-task setup that's
exactly what we saw on the diagram you
feed documents and queries for documents
you output their document id for queries
you output the corresponding document id
and you have some ratio of how many
indexing
samples and how many query samples that
go in
turns out that second method is better
which
i i don't know if i would have guessed
that but
um
yeah it kind of makes sense because it's
cleaner and you can you can essentially
scale and distribute there's no ordering
effect there's no catastrophic
forgetting or anything like this
and yeah
so
that makes sense
so that's what they do
all right we'll get into the experiments
now
the data set is natural questions this
is a question answering data set and it
can be used for retrieval because the
data set essentially always contains a
question a passage which is usually
called the context and an answer
this is one data point now the idea is
that you look at the context and the
question and you find the answer inside
of it however you can make you can make
a retrieval data set out of this by
forgetting about the answer and by
severing the connection between the
context and the query and considering
the entire data set
and essentially the task is now
if you if i have a given query a given
question which which context is the
correct one to go with that question
so you can make a retrieval data set
which is usually quite hard because um
the data set is made
with the fact in mind that you will get
the context right
so it is not necessarily the same as a
user typing something into google where
they need to look for a for a document
the question is a question about
the document if you already have the
document
so
it is a little bit it is it is an okay
data set for retrieval but it's just
not a direct retrieval data set also
note that it's kind of like 300 there's
300k data points they make subset of
that so they make a 10k
a 100k
10k dataset 100k dataset and a 300k
dataset so a small medium and large
although even the the large one right is
not very large you can because
in a search task
300 000 documents it seems a lot but if
you build search applications that is
not that is not a lot of documents right
a lot of document collections have
millions of documents and and more that
you need to retrieve from but it is good
to observe scaling properties right here
but just keep in mind that their largest
data set is still not super duper large
um
the other thing you can see they have
train pairs and validation pairs and
that
kind of
yeah so these all of these things they
have a special notion right here which
i'm not exactly sure i have to be honest
how this is exactly done so the training
pairs i have the queries and the context
both right and for the validation pairs
i also have queries and context now
usually i train a question answering
system i train on these things right
with the answers and then i input these
things over here at inference time
however if i train a search index i
certainly need to index at least the
contexts of the validation pairs and i
simply prohibit myself from ever seeing
the queries
so what i think
they do what i think they do is they i
think they take these
together
they this these are all the contexts all
the documents
and they take the queries from the
training set
and that makes sort of the the
quote-unquote training set right this
this here would be
indexing
and this here would be fine tuning
and then they evaluate this here would
be eval but this is a hypothesis of mine
i'm not exactly sure that that's what
they do because certainly they can't
just not index the data that they're
going to retrieve from right
but
i hope they don't actually fine tune on
the queries that are in the validation
set
but again maybe they also first do this
and then as a last step they then index
the validation set i'm not sure just
honestly and i couldn't read from the
paper maybe i've overlooked something
but it would be good question to the
authors how this exactly is done
training regiment seems pretty decent so
this it's google research so they have
the big chips um
yeah t5 isn't exactly a small model
right especially the larger ones so here
are the results and
they are all over the place which makes
me a little bit skeptical first you can
see in general the larger models for the
differentiable search index generally
outperform the smaller models by a lot
right you can see here for example these
are large models these are small models
on the same task these are hits at 1 and
hits at 10
which means
if the correct answer is in the top one
or the top 10 respectively
for all of the dsi models that's the
case by the way when it says t5 here
that is a dual encoder baseline and
above here you can see the bm25 baseline
now also i would like to
um
[Music]
i would like to
draw your attention to the fact that
bm25 on the small data set it gets like
a performance of 12.4 on the large data
set it gets like 11.6 which you know is
reasonable it kind of goes down a bit if
the data set is larger because it can
confuse the documents a bit more but in
general it's constant but then there's
like a big jump in this 100k data set
like what's up
what's what's up with that um this seems
to this seems to be
weird uh so
you can't really see that in the dual
encoder setup there is a jump here but
that remains
um
then if you if you look at
if you look at these small models here
it goes up and it goes down again yeah
that's the same trend but then here if
you can see it kind of goes down in
performance
and then it goes
up
no it goes it kind of remains down
all i'm saying is this is
not okay this might be to be expected
this might be expected because
uh
going down in performance is what i
would expect
if it goes if the data set becomes
larger okay
but there are some inconsistencies
among here yeah all the weirder that
here actually goes up
and as you can see the highlighted bits
right here for example um this thing
uh
the methods that work they seem to be
all over the place sometimes this naive
string doc id is the best um sometimes
this semantic string doc id is the best
the clear trend is that pretty much
everywhere the larger models are better
which i think is reasonable to say
because they're going to have more
capacity of adopting the data into their
weights
and in other
trends the larger the data set gets the
worse the models become again like look
at this it goes down to be expected it
goes up again what's up
um
so this data set is just is cursed uh so
we won't look at it
so let's just compare the very left and
the very right things
uh you can also you can also see that
uh there is a big improvement over bm25
which is surprising right
that even the dual encoders
improve over bm25 but this
differentiable search index especially
if it gets large improves by quite a bit
now i suspect again that that is kind of
the nature of the data set right here
but it
might as well be that the
all the embedding techniques are very
good
but
yeah um
lastly what i want to point out oh yeah
the improvement over the dual encoders
uh of the differentiable search index so
over this baseline right here this gets
smaller and smaller as the data set
grows right which we discussed at the
beginning and which i think is a little
bit of a bad sign for these types of
techniques in that
obviously as i have more data i cannot
really save it into my weights as easily
and the dual encoders they are not
like the embedding space high
dimensional embedding space is kind of
infinite right
so
um i can save a lot of stuff there no
matter how much data i have it'd be
interesting though because uh there are
techniques in which you can
like if i have a matrix and i want to
store stuff in that matrix as long as
that stuff as long as
i build like low rank matrices that i
add to it or
um in vector terms if i build like
vectors that are largely orthogonal to
one another i can you know stay save a
lot of stuff in a single matrix by just
adding to it
um or to a vector space or to a set of
vectors
and maybe
maybe you know with a bit of trickery
in how the weights are updated exactly
for the different documents one could
improve this quite a bit
this here is zero the zero shot setting
which means this models they never see
any queries they never learn to map
queries to document ids they simply
learn to map documents to doc ids which
is an additional difficulty
again you can see that
the weirdness of bm25 right that's
exactly the same right bm25 is gonna
perform the same because bm25 is always
zero shot he never sees
labeled queries uh you can you just
can't i mean i guess you can
you can also run it through indexing but
uh yeah
interestingly
the dual encoder in um
in a zero shot fashion just sucks it
really sucks
the sentence t5 which is
explicitly made for like sentence
sentence similarity
it is apparently okay it apparently
outperforms bm25
also i have trouble believing that but
you know if they say so
but then
these dsi they really shine in this
especially here this atomic dock id
method
for some reason it really is is really
good
um as you can see
it outperforms the
semantic string dock id which was kind
of
the best one before or one of the best
one also this naive string dock id was
really good
before it outperforms that in a zero
shot setting so the
results are kind of all over the place
and that is what worries me a little bit
in that it seems to be quite noisy
they themselves admit or
report that training with these atomic
dock ids seems to perform well in the
zero shot setting but it's also quite
unstable
so
uh yeah it's a it's a cool method cool
paper
um and it shows some really interesting
results
but it also seems that there's quite a
bit of noise and probably we haven't
exactly figured out many of those things
yet which is a good thing if you're in
research
uh
yeah
so they find a bunch of things like in
general they say structured semantic
identifiers are helpful and improve over
unstructured ones however we also note
that unstructured atomic identifiers
perform the best by a wide margin on the
zero shot retrieval setup
who knows why
we can i guess we can hypothesize the
other methods i've already
discussed a little bit um especially
model size it seems to be really
important as you can see for dual
encoders that doesn't pay that much of a
that doesn't make super duper difference
um it makes much more difference for the
differentiable search index whereas if
you talk about data set size a higher
data set size seems to be much more
detrimental to the differentiable search
index than it is to a dual encoder
interestingly also the length of the
tokens you index per document seems to
be
better if it's kind of shorter
which is interesting so
if you index the same documents for
longer for more tokens that seems to
hurt performance and really if you go
much much longer
and lastly
uh here they investigate how much
indexing versus retrieval they have to
feed in during the multi-task training
uh if they train index and uh labeled
query pairs at the same time turns out
that's also fairly noisy but you can't
go too high
um one seems to be fine right so you can
get an improvement if you have more
indexing but one seems to be fine which
is already relieving i think
you could just mix them together and
you'd be fine
um
yeah i wanted to say one
one more thing
yes so in their conclusion
they talk about
document identifiers and they say it
would be interesting to explore
alternative strategies for representing
documents and doc ids including
end-to-end strategies for learning
semantic identifiers
that's that's what they say because
they're kind of unsatisfied with the way
they represent the document ids uh
because they the height of their method
is this hierarchical clustering which is
also it uses a separate encoder and so
on however
i'm thinking myself yo if you want this
to be learned like end to end and so on
isn't that like isn't that exactly like
regressing to cross encoder setup and
dense retrieval setup isn't that
essentially what you're doing if you're
learning these things end to end
i don't know exactly how then that's
going to be different in principle
and this is my a little bit of my worry
about this paper as well that they
didn't compare at all to any cross
encoder uh set up to any any kind of
re-ranking setup that are very prevalent
in neural search these days any dense
retriever set up
maybe dense retriever is by encoder i'm
not even sure
but
i feel these are some
some baselines that are missing right
here along with the smaller size of the
data set but all in all pretty cool
again i don't think this is necessarily
going to be such
a use in search in itself like search
through document collections but much
more could be very useful as a part in
for example a reinforcement learning
agent
who has to
store stuff during the episode and then
retrieve it later in a very
differentiable manner in an addressable
manner it would also be interesting to
see
yeah whether
whether outputting document ids
is better than outputting the
information that i want directly right
because you could also think of that you
could also say you know here is a query
just output the document itself or the
part of the document that matches
instead of outputting the document id
you know how does that perform it it
will be equally interesting
to see that
so lots of things to research i really
like this paper because it does
something different
it does something weird and it puts in
the engineering effort to figure out
what makes it work and what doesn't and
yeah that's it let me know what you
think in the comments i'll see you
around bye
[Music]
you